[Music]
maybe a massage
not like
under the same blanket massage but like
you didn't have to clarify that okay
now this is really turned into a fantasy
and we're like this so we're face to
face so if we want to talk to each other
we can but we're a little farther apart
you know right weird cause i bet you
he's got great stories george clooney's
got some great stories
i'd be lying to you if i haven't
pictured me and brad pitt walking down
the beach hand-in-hand just to
if you could hold hands with one dude on
the beach it would be brad pitt for me
you know what brad pitt across the board
and let me tell you why
i think he's funny
you remember brad pitt
no
here's how i imagine
a date
with me and georgetown this is my dad's
fantasy with george clooney
not a fan
i'm just thinking about it right now but
i think we opened up with like some
morning basketball you think he's
warming up in the morning
over 60 clooney still [__] yeah
clooney do you google that i want to
know
clooney has his routine
on the internet i i've heard stories i
think that clooney is a hooper
i could be wrong but i heard that he'd
like to take those old man ankles
i bet you clooney
has some sneaky dirty
and he throws elbows for sure do you
think so oh yeah past a certain age you
have to if you're a dude you're one of
two guys
you either
stand outside the three-point line yep
on both sides offense and defense yep
and take set shots for threes yep
or you're underneath
with goggles a headband two knee braces
and you're the dirtiest player of all
time and we're fighting
because if i catch an elbow when you
swing around we're gonna i'm gonna get
up and swing an elbow like there's no
like here's the thing man like that
if you're on the court and you're doing
[__] like that
as long as you're over 18 these hands
are ready to eat for everybody
i mean so
we're just having a good time talking
about old dudes playing at the y and why
are you talking about knuckle sandwiches
and that's why i say morning hoops
then maybe a massage
not like
under the same blanket massage but like
you didn't have to clarify that okay
now this is really turned into a fantasy
know that it's like a massage
and and we're like this so we're face to
face so if we want to talk to each other
we can but we're a little farther apart
you know what i mean weird because i bet
you he's got great stories george
clooney's got some great stories
and then probably a little you know like
a lunch
you're trying to give me a snack what's
eating for lunch
i don't know man i bet you at his villa
he's got somebody making some [__] up
over there in italy he lives in italy
i'm assuming this all happens in italy
on his property this should have been
stated at the beginning
oh where did you think we were studio
city yes somewhere in l.a no man we're
in italy we're on his property what is
the social eleven
this is just there's not eleven this is
just two
this is ocean's two
me and you that's what it's called and
then so
we do all that lunch on his property and
then i think his property is in the
water
so after lunch on the load we go out for
a little boat ride
maybe do a little fishing
i mean i think he's on lake cuomo i
don't know if you can fish out there
but we definitely can do a boat ride
smoke a little wave
you smell sweet
yeah
yes this is
you know the craziest fantasy it's not a
fantasy it is a fantasy you don't have
every aspect of it i've never thought of
it you had to clarify that the massage
wasn't sexual
for just for people nah
nah because if it wasn't a fantasy have
you never been on the internet before
dude you got to be super specific
are you [__] kidding me you know
somebody was gonna call you out for it
if it wasn't me though i did you had to
clarify well it doesn't matter more
people would have been like under the
same blanket you holding each other's
dicks you know what i mean people are
still gonna face your whole nature
without a doubt
but i
notice there's no
dick holding
okay sorry following again by the way
for the second time
listen and you keep saying fantasy i was
just it came to me i'm just giving you
what i think it okay did it did it come
true right now
we're on the boat if i don't want to
boat now after lunch what else you got
to do i'm just i'm i'm just checking in
you're jumping from spot to spot i don't
know there's nothing we're still on the
property
hours a day we smoke a little weed we
play a little cards on the boat what
cardigan i bet you he we could probably
set up a table and bring a
dealer and just play a little blackjack
i think he doesn't have high stakes
texas hold him under his boat
100 grand entrance a quick cameo from
like matt damon and brad pitt and look
let me tell you something cameos are
always welcome
we're on the boat we're smoking weed
maybe maybe i get on an inner tube in
the back one of those situations
and we play a little 21
but 21. okay
wait a second
we come back yo you know what i've been
in the sun a lot a lot of exercise
smoking weed i'm gonna take a little nap
before dinner so you just have to take a
nap or he decides to take a nap me i
take it got it
because you have yoga yeah i wake up
uh my alarm goes off and there's a knock
on the door
and the
i am brought in
just a little coffee just a little quick
pick me up before dinner
i get ready for dinner
we
go downstairs
lobster
bing bang boop
take a couple mushrooms
just go out on the boat firework display
this this is a fantasy no come on man
this is team josh or team jacob also on
this one like this this sounds like
yeah but a fantasy implies something
that i've thought of for a long time it
sounds like you thought a lot about it i
was this is the first time i've ever
thought of it but i'm saying
huh cat
he said that wasn't the first time you
thought about this and i said cap which
means you're lying
oh no why would i think about a date
with george clooney i'm a pit dude all
the way but i had never thought about
what a david clooney would be but
clooney seems like such a cool dude and
he probably has all of those he has weed
he has mushrooms he could get his own
firework he has a boat he has weed he
has uh uh cards to play poker and he's
got chips i thought we're playing 21.
uh 21. you know what i'm saying like
he's got all these things he's got a
basketball court on his property okay
that's that's believable that's blue oh
actually all of this is pretty
believable not me except for the fact
that it's you and george
[Music]
we gotta go